War turns the inside out
in one bright searing millisecond the
private becomes public homes are ripped
open and people and the possessions of a
lifetime spread across the street
I hope this madness will be over one day
why are people experiencing such a
nightmare how many people die we lived
we worked it was over everything our
life I hope for a better future but I
don't know but for tonight I have
somewhere to sleep
thankfully Maria and her family were out
but several people were killed when the
missile arrived in vishkarod the
Russians presumably aimed for the nearby
power plant and missed
but across the country enough energy
targets were hit to leave much of
Ukraine without electricity or water
the government is setting up so-called
Invincible points so people can warm up
people can come here to drink some tea
or coffee to spend time in a warm place
to eat some cookie or church their
phones if it's basic but as winter bites
in Earnest it could be the difference
between life and death
or millions of ukrainians this is their
current existence walking up endless
flights of stairs in dark apartment
buildings with no water and no heat
let's check this Radiator on the wall
yeah Stone Cold
lives on the eighth floor with her
husband and young son
for them the gloom and the chill is
inconvenient but no emergency
thank you
they fight the blackouts with technology
both modern
there's the Christmas atmosphere
and old the life is different it's a bit
strange yeah to live in Kiev and to use
this like this thing to prepare the tea
do you think the Russians are hoping
that these missile attacks hitting the
electricity will break the will of the
people here I don't know any person who
is ready like to go to the negotiations
with Russians because of this like
missiles they strikes
aliona is confident confident the power
will be back on soon and that Ukrainian
resistance will not be broken
challenge Al Jazeera key of region